on est aujourd'hui à munich pour
l'enterrement de vie de garçon de mon
pote flou tout cela génial que les
garçons ça va ça se passe bien voilà bon
voilà c'est pour quand ça se pose là
t'es mignon comme ça jamais te l'envoie
directement à toutes ces petites landes
[Musique]
pour parler justement des nouvel ipod
touch qui a été sortie annoncée en tout
cas par un peu en catimini directement
sur leur site internet
est ce que c'est vachement intéressant
il ya plein de choses à dire je pensais
pas que apple allait continuer moi je
n'ai pas vu la marche celle à savoir
tout va bien on sait pas qu'apple allait
continuer avec un la gamme ipod touch et
ça continue dans la série pourquoi pas
on va se trouver un petit coin pour
poser le pied là il ya un bel endroit
pour poser mon pied va se mettre là on
devrait quand même relativement pas mal
je suis parti pour quelques jours à
munich avec justement des potes en faire
un enterrement de vie de garçon
mais plutôt bien justement je me suis
dit vas y faut quand même que je vous
parle de ça parce que comprends pas je
ne vois pas pourquoi apple nous remet un
ipod touch au goût du jour quelques
années après alors bon je dirais que
c'est un truc qui va quand même
relativement disparaître tout simplement
parce que lorsque tout le monde achète
son smartphone à smartphone comme ça
vous allez tous vous avez vos
applications vous avez votre musique
vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
voulez avec sans aucun problème donc
quelle est la stratégie derrière le fait
de dire bah tiens on va prendre ça va
flanc je vous rejoins tout à l'heure
ouais là bas au fond là trois quarts
d'heure quelle est la stratégie pour
apple justement de mettre cet ipod touch
au goût du jour aujourd'hui
ça me paraît compliqué parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a tous des smartphones
des smartphones qui ont des applications
dans lequel on met de la musique on peut
tout faire dans tout ce que vous pouvez
faire avec le nouvel ipod touch 2019
vous digéré votre smartphone donc quand
on voit que quand même l'ensemble des
français dit quasiment l'ensemble
sont équipés de smartphones donc on
s'introduit qui fait doublon quelle est
la stratégie des regards simple alors
déjà avant toute chose je vous présente
et très très très très rapidement de
produits vous avez une puce un
processeur soc qui est pas hyper hyper
récent c'est pas le dernier c'est le à
dix on n'aura pas donc les plus grosses
performances par rapport à ce que vous
trouvez aujourd'hui chez apple mais
c'est en tout cas un truc qui se tient
on a là un écran 4 pouces lcd dont quand
on vraiment sûr un form factor un peu au
secours mais depuis quand même un peu
old school avec ce petit écran lcd de 4
pouces
on a un bouton home en bas sans tod
chaibi on n'a bien évidemment pas du
tout la possibilité d'insérer une carte
sim donc de ne pas boire téléphone avec
on s'en doutera d'ajouter c'est pas un
iphone on peut pas avoir de date parents
directs hors connexion wifi j'ai
toujours une prise jack donc on voit que
c'est vraiment un appareil qui est
destiné pour pouvoir aller écouter de la
musique en mode baladeur avec un jack il
est dispo en couleurs et en termes de
tarifs chez tous noté là vous avez la
version 32 gigas 249 euros 128 giga 359
euros et 250 gigas à 469 l'eurusd crois
qu'on est sur un produit qui a trop cher
dans la gamme apple on est sur un
baladeur par rapport à l'écosystème et
la marque apple qui va pas être trop
cher en gros c'est un iphone de vieilles
vieille génération tôt sur les iphone 4
iphone 5 pas cher sans possibilité de
pouvoir téléphoner et pourquoi est ce
qu'ils ont laissé une prise jack tout
simplement parce que comme il se destine
à un public qui va pas forcément mettre
beaucoup d'argent sur un produit comme
celui là et bien vous avez pas forcément
avoir un casque bluetooth qui va coûter
le même prix voire un peu plus cher que
l'appareil donc une prise jack ça marche
d'autant plus que tout le monde va pas
se brancher avec les câbles lightning
l'idée c'est que vous avez plein
lightning vous rechargez vos entreprises
déjà que vous écoutez nous avons un
appareil qui est tout le temps
disponible pour de la musique mais pas
que alors la question c'est à quoi sert
justement cette paille punch de 2019
mais c'est exactement la même chose que
les anciens ipod touch à écouter de la
musique à jouer à des jeux que ce soit
en ligne ou hors ligne et notamment avec
un peu l'arcade qui va arriver dans
quelques temps qui pourrait jouer aussi
avec de la réalité augmentée ce apple
croit énormément à la réalité augmentée
donc ça va continuer à se développer et
vous pourrez le faire notamment avec la
puce à 10
c'est pas la plus performante pour quand
même utiliser vous savez par exemple les
jeux illégaux en réalité augmentée c'est
pour rire car ce sera quand même plutôt
pas mal
vous pourrez envoyer des messages via un
message lorsque vous serez connecté bien
évidemment en wifi vous aurez bien
évidemment accès à la gestion de votre
temps d'écran et vous pourrez
télécharger plein d'applications dans
l'app store en gros avec votre ipod
touch pourrait faire tout ce que vous
faites avec votre iphone sans téléphoner
bien évidemment avec beaucoup moins de
performance et puis un design carrément
jusqu'où la question c'est quelle est la
stratégie d'apple derrière tout ça parce
que vous avez quand même un produit avec
un look qui quand même relativement au
school déjà que les iphone 10 iphone 10s
commence à vieillir début 2010' fly nous
propose une machine avec un truc qui est
carrément ils ceux du passé en terme de
design parce qu'un ipod touch s'est
jamais qu'un iphone sans la possibilité
de pouvoir téléphoner comme je vous le
disais tous les smartphones permettent
de faire ce que fait un ipod touch même
des smartphones qui vont coûter 200 300
euros des smartphones chinois ou autres
donc bon on se dirait quel intérêt alors
effectivement la grosse force de frappe
c'est derrière vous avez un hayon est ce
que vous n'avez pas sur des smartphones
chinois à ce tarif là mais bon est-ce
que ça suffit à justifier en tout cas le
retour total punch
alors pourquoi faire revenir ce produit
début 2019 enfin derrière tout ça je
pense que apple a une stratégie que le
contraire bien écrite c'est vrai quand
je les ai vus arriver je me suis dit
c'est un peu what the fuck personne va
aller sur ce produit de personnes
d'aller acheter
mais au final je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus malin que ça et
connaissant une boîte comme apple avec
l'importance qu'ils ont ils sortiraient
pas un ipod touch pour dire on remet un
ipod touch au goût du jour alors que
personne n'aurait acheté
non c'est beaucoup plus malin il une
vraie stratégie derrière parce que au
final cet ipod touch qui se destine à un
public qui est relativement jeune pour
moi l'ipod touch il est destiné à un
public entre 16 et 12 ans c'est à dire
un public qui n'a pas encore l'âge
d'avoir un smartphone mais qui par
contre halage aujourd'hui d'avoir un
appareil connecté qui du moins peut
l'utiliser comme j'irai un baladeur
console qui peut emmener partout avec
lui imaginez c'est hyper simple vous
êtes pas on sait pas si vous n'êtes pas
moi personnellement je le suis moi mon
enfant à 7 il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui
elliott mais dans deux ans elliot
lorsqu'il aura sept ans dans un peu plus
de huit ans je pars a forcément envie de
lui acheter un smartphone pour pouvoir
appeler ses potes à 7 8 ans ça me paraît
quand même relativement jeune par contre
on va bien que les enfants aujourd'hui
sont plus en plus précoces notamment sur
l'utilisation de tablettes
ordinateur pour jouer pour ses côtés
multimédia et même sur les smartphones
vous leur passé ils ont leur petit jeu
s'amuse bien avec mes deux l'aller leur
payer un abonnement téléphonique et deux
là ce qu'ils avaient eux mêmes leur
propre smartphone entre 7 et 12 ans ça
me paraît quand même relativement
déconnant et justement je pense que
c'est la stratégie qu'apple met en place
c'est à dire avoir un device sur lequel
vous allez pouvoir jouer écouter de la
musique vous connecter aux réseaux
sociaux ça encore avoir ça dépend
vraiment des parents parce que les
réseaux sociaux il ya un âge où ses
patrons moment mais pas contre le fait
d'avoir des petits jeux d'arcade
moi mon fils il aime bien jouer à tom le
chat sur le sur mon smartphone alors
vraiment occasionnels mais de temps en
temps il aime bien faire sa petite
partie de comme le charme pour pouvoir
regarder ses dessins animés sur you tube
kids ou alors carrément sur netflix est
son compte enfants donc ça a un sens
l'idée de le proposer un public jeunes
entre 7 et 12 ans voire 12 15 ans avant
le smartphone en fait c'est l'objet
connecter avant le smartphone je pense
que c'est vraiment là-dessus qu'apple
vient le maître est d'ailleurs lorsque
vous regardez sur le site d'apple
vous voyez le public qu'on vous présente
via les photos on voit qu'on a accès à
un public en même qui est relativement
jeune en mains publiques pré ado ado on
ne met pas des adultes dans la force de
l'âge en train d'utiliser ce produit
après si vous êtes adulte ça nous
empêche absolument pas d'utiliser ce
produit par exemple vous avez un
smartphone android et que vous voulez
quand même
eyeos de l'autre côté ne vous avais pas
envie d'acheter un iphone coûtera une
relativement cher mais vous voulez
profiter d'applications ios ça peut
avoir un sens et je pense aussi
je reviens sur mon public un peu plus
jeune mais à des jeux moi par exemple je
sais qu'elle disait que son bâtiment
sympa en réalité augmentée bon joué
notamment avec les lego va vous faites
ça avec votre votre enfant vous le fil à
votre enfant
il as ces jeux lego il peut jouer en
réalité augmentée avec ma chance ça
vraiment sympa et en plus vous le voyez
il faut un gros focus sur l'application
de gestion du temps d'utilisation
lorsque vous êtes parent vous inquiète à
ce que votre enfant fasse pas trop de
temps sur les écrans et là dessus aussi
ça un sens à 100 mais voilà je vais
pouvoir contrôler je vais pouvoir
regarder combien de temps ils patientent
à l'application on va pouvoir réguler
quitte à lui enlever lorsqu'ils passent
trop de temps dessus lui rendra fin
voilà ya quand même une vraie belle
stratégie derrière donc pour moi c'est
une stratégie plutôt maligne de la part
d'apple ça leur permet de renforcer leur
positionnement sur un public un peu le
jaune ou en tout cas pourquoi pas
devenir draguer un public ciblé un peu
plus jeunes et lorsque vous êtes
habitués un os vous l'utilisez depuis
vous êtes gamin vous avez encore plus
d'affect avec ce qui fait qu'une femme
vous serez adultes jeunes adultes et
bien qu est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez continuer à consommer du produit
apple allait dans l'écosystème à rester
sur un os parce que vous savez
déjà je sais pas vous par exemple mais
moi je regarde mes souvenirs quand
j'étais jeune vous êtes beaucoup de
nostalgie sur les produits vous utilisez
avant sur les usages que vous aviez par
rapport à un moment à une époque
donc ça peut vraiment avoir un sens vous
dire bah voilà si on arrive à marquer
les gens qui sera public jeune 7 12 15
ans ils vont avoir de l'affection avec
la marque font vraiment créer un lien
donc une fois qu'ils seront adultes
jeunes adultes des mecs vont rester avec
la marque tout ça c'est intéressant
c'est très mal en fait parce que quand
je regarde je me dis mais c'est quoi
l'idée en fait voilà l'essence produit
au final il n'y a un vrai sens une vraie
belle stratégie marketing d'ailleurs dit
pas ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
est ce que vous pourriez vous l'achetez
en tant qu'adulte qui saisit d'un public
plutôt jeune
est ce que ça pourrait vous tenter et si
vous êtes en eau est ce que vous pouvez
l'acheter aux autres voilà vous marquez
tout sauf bons commentaires moi je
retourne au préparer parce que prendre
un notamment d'élire son affaire c'est
pas tout et comme vous le savez c'est
aussi beaucoup à lui aura pas de match